So I think that there is a special function that's
only for pickles fields, but I can't remember what it
was. Maybe we should, copy and paste that error into
Google and see if it tells us what that error is?
>> Formula for pickless field.
>> Right here, awesome,. Ellen Williams. So, she
also is writing an if statement that's using
pickless values. And so you can see here, if is pick val, which is the function
that you need to use, that's the, stage name
is the field, and then pending is probably the
pickless value. So if the stage name is pending,
do this. So we need to use that also.
>> It's funny that she was dealing with stages, too.
[LAUGH]
>>
[INAUDIBLE]
>> So let's grab from the functions on the right, and over here.
>> Uh-huh.
>> We can grab text. ISPICVAL.
>> Yep. ISPICVAL.
>> There it is.
>> Okay and where to do we want to put this if?
>> In that first, yeah, over the Ticket Type VIP.
>> Okay, then like, pick this field.
It's going to be ticket type, and the text is VIP.
>> Yep. Alright, let's check the syntax now. Awesome.
>> That's cool. Alright. This formula's a bit of a
beast. I would not have come up with it by myself.
But I guess Google was a good, good tool. Is
that something you find yourself doing a lot when you're developing?
>> yeah. I mean, because, we're not supposed to remember
everything. And so, definitely whenever I run into errors, I'll Google
the error itself because a lot of people have ran into
the same things before. There's also in the upper right hand corner
these Quick Tips for getting started, seeing samples, more examples. I mean,
there's a lot of tools available if you are new to formulas.
>> Cool.